Stars, galaxy, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, over wings, is such a wonder thing, behind us all grump, see come take your place, leaving soon for, possess and send them and, to mate them, and that is my final word, 34 hours to surrender to my government, otherwise, how do I perfectly, give up, then it's war, and I guarantee you I'll eat them in one bite, generally eat them, according to, their new heavy cruisers are now,
operational and they are remarkable even our present nautiluses will blow them out of the sky
but what we're waiting for that's something else the eagles of space giants compared to these their
new cruisers are like little chicks tiny tiny chicks tiny tiny tiny tiny mysterious allies
who are furnishing weapons will you general but the great day is almost at hand i see no reason
not to satisfy your curiosity our allies are located in the nebula mgc 6188 in the southern
region of Scorpio. Their capital
is Yama. That's where they manufacture
our wonderful weapons, and they
will go on supplying us for as long
as we tell them. They are human.
Not exactly. I wouldn't actually say that.
What the? Machines. Robots.
That's what they are. Why not? They're
ruled by the great computer. And now
the fossil who spent some time there
on mission will tell you.
They're extraordinary. Such power, such
attention to detail. Highest technology.
It's inhuman. Yes, quite so. Inhuman.
May I say it was a very lucky day for Cassiopeia.
When they agree to be on our side, we're lucky with weapons like the ones they're making for us.
Distinguished Consul, if this power is as you describe it,
what assurance have you that they will continue on our side?
Always a choker, aren't you, Professor?
Can't you understand?
The computer in command was originally programmed by a man,
and as such is always faithful to man.
All right, now we vote on the ultimatum to Omega.
Megans are human as we are.
It's ridiculous for us to go to war with them.
Six votes plus mine, that counts double.
Resolution adapted.
Send this ultimatum to Omega at once and make sure they understand.
I want their answer within 24 hours.
Gone.
My plan.
Once we take Omega, we go after the ones on Yama.
Yeah, but one fish to fry at a time.
I got all kinds of good ideas.
What's that?
Who said you could bother me?
General, a message from the great computer.
Ultra urgent.
Yeah?
Announces the arrival of his giant cruisers, as agreed.
Huh? What is who? An ultimatum surrender unconditionally within 24 hours. How dare they? That's what they want, that's what they'll get. I declare general mobilization. They're all going to see. Grouchley won't take this.
General, explain clearly what the situation is and let any decision be brought to a vote before declaring anything.
General, withdraw the ultimatum to Omega and ask him to come and fight on our side.
The time always comes when the stupidest thinks he's the wisest and he decides to use his brute power instead of using his brain power.
Why, this is mutiny, this is treason! Who's in command here? It's high time, this was all sorted out, Chief.
Guards arrest them! All of them! I alone take command of the state!
Good for you, Chief.
Yama, now hanging over the Confederation, weren't enough.
Now we have just received a curtly worded ultimatum from Cassiopeia.
To brief you, gentlemen, I will call on the Chief of our Intergalactic Force, Colonel Pierre.
Pierre. Against Yama, strategically speaking, we have clearly no possible chance of success.
Against Cassiopeia, our new heavy cruisers could probably come out on top, though outnumbered.
We are surely all in agreement on Cassiopeia. Yes, but trying to wage a war on two fronts,
that seems to me a folly in the extreme. Yes, why not offer to join the General as allies against
Yama? I had the same idea, Dr. Newman, but as long as he thinks Yama is his ally, he will
certainly refuse any such alliance very serious news has just reached us the
great computer has just delivered an ultimatum to General Grouchy yes yes just
as he told us he would one day well then he would accept our alliance he has no
choice now he has to accept and together we would at least have a chance oh not
much of a chance no why don't we impose one condition that Cassiopeia rejoin the
Confederation and then we can go to their assistance very well and am I right
in assuming that the Colonel's proposition is accepted unanimously?
Rejoin their confederation?
Now that I am sole ruler?
Never!
Anyway, for all the good the confederation could do us, who cares?
Yeah, one, two, three, and I'll grind up both of them.
Computer, Yama, Omega, all.
I am the greatest.
I will smash them.
Smash them?
Like you say, Chief?
Our fleet is approaching, General.
The first vessels are joining formation.
Now you know your honors,
you are to fire without warning at anything that moves in the sky.
Any Omega ship is a legitimate target.
Goes humanity's last bluffing, no doubt.
What do we do? Help him anyway?
I see no reason to risk the destruction of our ships under the circumstances.
They will be needed for the real fight.
What do we do then?
I'm largely in agreement with Professor Big Head.
We have to go to his assistance despite his conduct.
His fight is our fight.
Why not send out a few little ships?
We should create a diversion and distract them since our forces are not adequate.
In any case, we should have observation units in position.
We must have up-to-the-minute intelligence reports to judge the situation.
Here's what I suggest. A couple of light craft hummingbirds as distraction.
And we'll have a light destroyer as observation posts some distance away to come to their assistance if necessary.
You are the only crew who's had any direct experience with the enemy.
You know how they react. That is why we call on you.
Well, Captain?
I'm in total agreement with your decision, Colonel, and we have a score to settle with them.
But for my plan to work, I'll need two more crew members. I'd like them.
One hummingbird will do.
Now here's what I suggest.
We approach the enemy, and we try to penetrate their fortifications.
Stand by, fire without warning, and shoot to kill. Now, off you go.
Ethiopians, give yourselves up. Why fight it?
The general on.
Half of our forces engaged so far have been destroyed.
I've just received the following message.
If you haven't a chance, give yourselves up. Why fight it?
What? We give up? Never, you understand? Never!
Send in the other units. Go ahead. Show them who we are. Go on.
Yeah, show them who we are.
As you ordered, General. Forward third line of cruisers. Engage the enemy.
Must be in here again side by side in this little crate just like the old days. Don't you think so?
Yes, it's true. But our mission isn't very funny. Maybe we shouldn't think about it too much.
Things don't go just right. There's a good chance that this will be the last act for all of us.
Sure, only we've seen worse. Remember those Watcher McCullochs, the Saurians on the green planet?
Yeah, that was a school picnic compared to this one.
And the rocket bomb headed for Earth.
This is the commander. Here's where we have to leave you.
You will be making contact soon.
Good luck to all of you. All our thoughts are with you.
All right, I'll go over the whole thing again. Every detail counts. Here goes.
The basis of my idea is that they wouldn't be programmed to notice our entry.
So the main problem is physically getting inside.
And also getting outside again so we live to tell the tale.
If I see them opening it, I record, decode.
In a word, I make the whole thing work just like a charm, as usual.
Yes, it's true, Metro. You're great.
Ah, yes. It all recalls the Trojan horse in Greek days.
You recall that in antiquity, there was a Trojan horse.
Well, all right. Culture can wait, as always.
The only trouble now is we won't be able to choose our target.
We have to follow them.
Follow their instructions and do what they say.
Now let's go over it again.
So far, our losses in engaging the enemy are 80%.
What do we do?
Their losses are great as well.
They're losing their ships too, and we still have our best ones in reserve. My Nautiluses, send them in.
Yes, sir. Of course, General. Sir, the enemy...
They will all die. Victory in the name of our glorious Cassiopeia and your general. You will win.
In the name of our glorious Cassiopeia and our general, we will win, as you say.
The enemy fleet, stand by. Ready for action. Combat stations.
Go ahead, start us off.
Okay, this is Bluebird transmitting a message for the forces of Yama. Message for Yama.
Do you read me?
I repeat, this is Bluebird from Omega transmitting to Yama.
Admit that you have no chance of winning.
Your logical choice is to surrender.
Any other choice will result in destruction.
Stand by.
First line, Nautilus, ready to engage the enemy.
Forward in the name of Cassiopeia.
Message to forces of Yama.
Hey, I hate to say it, Pierrot, but I have a hunch that your idea isn't going to work.
It has to work, otherwise there's...
They must have set some of their top specialists in motion,
their high-grade technicians, to analyze the voice patterns in the message.
Where this ship has come from. No doubt make deep space probes to know if we are alone.
Unless it's all a trap. Who knows what's going on?
This is Yama Battleforce. We have received your message. What do you want?
This is Bluebird from Omega. We have an important message, vital information.
It is imperative that we talk to your leader.
What sort of information is it? We will receive this information. Go ahead.
No, it's top secret. Priority message. We request permission to take refuge with you.
It is likely that we were followed. This is urgent.
Very well. Follow our instructions.
One of our spacecraft will escort you.
Our ship's destroyed, and not one hit by any of them.
What do we do now?
The general said fight to the end, so we fight to the end.
Admiral, it's not war anymore. It's pure suicide.
Our magnificent ship's all our men. Admiral.
Orders are orders, Commodore.
Second line of Nautilus ready to engage the enemy.
In the name of Cassiopeia.
Plus two, then six, minus four, leaves two.
Clear, come.
But there are two more inside, out in the cockpit.
Now, if you would like my opinion, be rather careful.
Don't make any noise, and naturally, warn Psyche.
Not a bad job, eh? What do you say?
Says they're gone.
Vaporize, sir.
Now it's, it's now a turn, sir.
This is the great computer.
It appears that your stupidity knows no limits.
You will not accept facts staring you in the face.
You force us to this final action.
This will be our last message.
Either you surrender within one hour or Cassiopeia itself, the entire planet.
End of message.
Getting to have my doubts about it, General.
Mistaken?
You didn't seriously believe I would make a mistake in bringing you here, did you?
Thirty minutes.
You think we can do it in that time?
When it explodes, we'd better be out and a good distance away.
Well, here goes.
Now let's find the main computer.
Yes, General.
That's what he said.
Either you surrender or we will vaporize Cassiopeia itself.
What kind of forces you got left?
Not even a tenth of our fleet, General.
Total disaster.
all our ships destroyed and they're going to blow up our dear planet it doesn't leave as much room
for maneuver we got no choice we got to surrender well when you got to you got to tell them i
surrender hey ship brain the seven minutes to get this far right i'll send it for 20 minutes
okay they won't trouble us but it gives us only a margin of three minutes what do you say now we
have to find them again let's go this one losing too much time this way metro let's go faster can't
work miracles vaporized vaporized as if the nautiluses never existed by the dozens colonel
it's truly extraordinary it's beyond belief it's just as you reported colonel they are invincible
our children any news of them commander none colonel heard anything since they contacted the
enemy well we appreciate your bringing us this information but was it as important as all that
Don't you realize, realize how important it is?
I tell you, Omega won't accept any of your conditions!
And they are arming with secret weapons right now!
What about us?
We don't want to die for Omega.
We're young, we want to live and have our own future.
Here with you.
Very well, I'll request instructions on your case.
In the meantime, you are to wait here.
Kindly follow us, if you please.
That's right, and make it quick.
See this star?
Extraordinary, Admiral.
What do we do? Fire on it?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Are you crazy?
No, don't try to fire on it. No, don't.
In case you didn't notice, there's another one.
Time limit has expired. What is your answer?
We accept. I mean refuse.
No, we surrender.
Unconditionally?
Unconditionally.
Very well.
Inform the general. We are sending units to Cassiopeia to govern the planet.
Also send units to take command of your ships.
Only seven minutes more before the computer blows up and blocks all the exits.
Fire.
Spaceship is ready for launching, Captain.
This is it. Is everybody on board ready?
Roger.
Okay, let's go, Metro.
Now, a little young man, I have a slight difficulty here.
But I recorded and stored the data.
4-2-2-3-7-1 on the other.
And 4-2-3-2-7-1.
Then again, 4-3-2-2-1-7.
The permutations are a bore.
And let's start all over again.
Metro, we have three minutes before this whole thing blows up.
Let's go!
Such a tone of voice. I'm doing my best.
By 4-2-3-1-7 or 4-3-2-1-7, it isn't all that difficult, surely.
Metro, two minutes!
It's like all Cassiopean force is broken.
Good news for anyone who survives this.
Nothing, Colonel.
And all combat has ceased.
I'm afraid we may have to consider them as lost.
It's 4-3-2-7-1.
It had to be that.
I must have Maestro checked my memory banks.
It takes so long on such a simple job.
I'll ask you, who was always forgotten?
So wonder places.